la espirometría es un examen para ver
cuán bien funcionan sus pulmones
midiendo cuán rápido y cuánto aire puede
inhalar y exhalar normalmente a medida
que respira o inhala el aire se mueve
libremente a través de su tráquea o tubo
aéreo luego a través de tubos anchos
llamados bronquios tubos más pequeños
llamados bronquiolos
y finalmente en pequeños sacos llamados
alveolos
pequeños vasos sanguíneos llamados
capilares rodean sus alveolos
y el oxígeno del aire que respira pasa a
través de sus capilares luego el dióxido
de carbono de su cuerpo pasa a través de
sus capilares hacia un alvéolo usted
elimina el dióxido de carbono cuando
expulsa el aire o exhala
enfermedades como el asma la bronquitis
y la fibrosis pulmonar estrechan sus
bronquios reduciendo la cantidad de aire
que va hacia sus pulmones
y enfermedades como el cáncer pulmonar y
el enfisema pueden dañar sus alveolos
reduciendo la cantidad de oxígeno en su
sangre
estas enfermedades pueden dificultar su
respiración
su médico puede recomendar una
espirometría para identificar una
enfermedad en sus pulmones revisar la
gravedad de su enfermedad pulmonar
existente o para determinar si los
medicamentos que está tomando están
ayudándolo
durante el examen su cuidador utilizará
un dispositivo llamado espirómetro un
espirómetro es una máquina que mide el
aire que exhala antes de que realice su
examen de espirometría usted estará
sentado en una cómoda silla con sus pies
apoyados completamente sobre el suelo si
tiene prótesis dentales se le puede
solicitar que se las retire para mejores
resultados se le aconsejará seguir las
instrucciones de su cuidador de forma
exacta para empezar levantara su cabeza
y su mentón de modo que pueda respirar
con mayor facilidad después se colocará
un gancho en la nariz para evitar que el
aire salga de sus fosas nasales
y luego tomará un respiro profundo
llenando completamente sus pulmones con
aire y reteniéndolo usted colocará el
dispositivo bucal del espirómetro entre
sus dientes y cerrará fuertemente sus
labios alrededor de él
finalmente usted expulsará el aire fuera
de sus pulmones tan fuerte y rápidamente
como pueda continuando respirando hasta
que su cuidador le diga que se detenga
si es un adulto usted soplará durante al
menos seis segundos los niños de diez
años y menos soplarán durante tres
segundos
usted necesitará realizar un examen de
espirometría correctamente tres veces
para obtener resultados precisos